well I think the way we're going to
proceed this evening is to have our
panelists speak for about 10 to 15
minutes and then allow them to ask
questions of one another but at the same
time open it up to questions from the
audience so we can begin with a
conversation why don't we begin with
Professor Africa that's impossible
thank you thank you for inviting me
again to Columbia University I'm
delighted to be here with you I was here
with use of thanks to use of energy and
organizing a while ago that far away and
was a very very interesting an enriching
experience leaving the countryside and
coming to the big city I feel like if
when i left the get to go to chiro let
it go and it's like I keep coming to
cities let me see since we have just
short time I would like to just share
with you a few ideas how what I'm about
to do is to such as how to think about
the current crisis more than maybe the
details of what goes on because as we
know it's a fluid situation and the
uprising is going and the regime refuse
to give up to the demands so what I'd
like to do is to share with you some
some may be a way of thinking about the
Libyan apprising within the larger
context of the people uprising in
tunisia egypt and maybe there's a fair
warning
hopefully more to come holla the fairest
um the first point of lighting to make
is to bring attention to the fact we
should avoid some obstacles that might
hinder hold our understanding of our
situation now and the case of Libya
there are two pitfalls I think or
filters that being grown by pundits and
also buy coverage and on some so-called
experts only the commentaries in crisis
the first one is due to focus solely on
the leader it def himself as really the
source of all on trouble but without
really contact social and historical
context of the good society and the
forces that brought his regime to power
and why the regime decay and run out of
steam and became so isolated in the face
of Libyan people the second obstacle at
my opinion with the ideology of
tribalism I hear it all the time and for
somebody who is specialist in this
social history I get very very mad and
sometimes I
I left because what what it does it's
mystifies the whole thing it brings
images of pre-modern or on time modern
society bested by disparate and really
it gives you a sense of comfort doesn't
explain much if you confuse but the does
it covers lack of knowledge and then one
thing you don't know and you say I don't
know much about society another thing is
to say okay out it's all tribal so the
ideology of tribalism which is rooted in
african studies in the past and what
goes on today is really also another
obstacle what I'm trying to say simply
is if we want to make sense of the
current democratic uprising then we have
to understand to bring you the guinea
society in and too green Libyan social
history and that's not going to be easy
because this is a small country but very
very complex and very very you had a
very rich tragic history in the 20th
century they are then moving to UM to
the how to think about the uprising the
democratic uprising now I would say
there are number of valid as I would
like to share with you the first is to
understand is what are the sources of
the crisis of the state the Libyan state
e second is
what are the sources of alienation elite
a nation third would be how people are
noble Isaac
sources immobilization and the final
point would be the ongoing struggle for
democratic rights and democratic
representative Libya in the future is it
really feasible is this going to happen
in the short term or in the long term or
is lydia's gonna are becoming forced to
become another Somalia or god forbid
another Iraq what are the scenarios for
the future faced with that the first if
you want to apply this analytical
framework and go beyond the persona of
Gaddafi and the fixation will Gaddafi
which is I think as a hindrance more
than a way of analyzing and
understanding the dynamics of society
negation Libya we have to say the first
source of this crisis would be the loss
of Nationals credentials and I have in
mind the disastrous war in Chad in the
middle 80s and the fact that the regime
did not even recognize the defeat and we
talking about Libyan death in five to
ten thousand
all estimates and to this day there is
no commission this and this aired court
is you know has been so horrendous and
in society many who died many lost many
they don't know what happened to them
and worse the trauma of not even
recognizing the war as you a huge that
war in my opinion was the beginning of
the larger crisis that hunted the regime
the disaster of Lockerbie we're bigger
society had to pay from his own wealth
over 20 billion dollars and the regime
managed to handle that very well lit by
the former's groups within the regime at
the same time no admission no apology to
the Libyan people no consultation that
further creates a sharpened the crisis
of the regime the
d the other sources of alienation now
moving from the state crisis would be
attackin da position and talkin about
Madonna versions liberal writers in
porous and novelist and journalist and
also socialist and history basically no
opposition was tolerated and when it's
the parties were banned and you know in
your organization would be treason that
was a major a source of radiation of
especially delete exclusion of of
different regions especially the
distribution has been marginalized in
the south to commit even toga dedicated
itself but the south and the east of
eden have been really much on our lives
very much the corruption widespread I'm
sure that many of you are serving or
read about WikiLeaks and also the you
know on the parties that cost millions
bringing en say Anna mariah carey and
others where dickens have to live mostly
get one three hundred dollars and one of
the richest countries in the whole
continent so you're talking about it
contradictions but also we talking about
the falling of the public institutions
even education and health system most
Libyans go to neighboring countries for
treatment the also the year on the
massacre of 1996 losing that use of
nation I think one of the it is haunted
the regime actually the whole uprising
started because of the families and that
lawyers and the seventh on rice
activists were trying to provide that
they make the state accountable for that
and the i would say also another source
of alienation would be the fact that
different people were very patient and
they tried to listen to say to me Sam at
the beginning taking that as the regime
would reform itself but what they will
go to the streets easy this is very very
universal thing and when the the reform
attempts failed and turn it to be just
venting or a cosmetic employed by the
regime and add to that the disaster
speeches by Gaddafi and his son reacting
to the Tunisian of
that really convinced not only the one
nobody related but lot vast majority
Philippians that decision is not
refundable and just a way to reform it a
judgment now lets me move quickly a long
time is limited to to the sources of
mass mobilization to add another
variable i would say that we have to
look at you know indirect impact like
population increased india has done we
think six and a half million people we
have the organization literacy rates one
of the highest and the whole continent
of africa also the the social network
despite the venom of a political parties
and the weakening of some conjecture
news we know that there has been revival
in the last ten years through blogs and
also through email website and also
satellite TV that connected Libyans with
the world in general and Asia in general
and also very vital of like the Writers
Union has been at the front of the Dean
struggle I have been privileged to be
part of a journal called origene ferns
that has been really trying to deepen
analysis of the situation in Libya and
also
I remember for example the blood of my
dear friend and one of the best da
critics individually say that's also
among others have even the understanding
and interaction beyond the state control
I would say also the all of this
institution and uncertainty of sorts of
our changing and organizing led to
sharpen the wetness of the firm of the
vid falls and the ground the way to
fight a very very entrenched regime that
refused to recognize any any
participation from the larger society
also the shortening of contradiction
between the rich and the poor further
you know added to that now there are
symbols beside the social mobilization
and institution like creating fighting
40 constitutional 1951 declaring that
the flag the dependence of that Israeli
assemble province identify if thinking I
think hopefully that will not be a
romantic idea about going back there
monarchy but also we should so far
interpreted as a way of alternative way
polarizing
the shape of revolutionary struggle mom
is really with us there is a coalition
that combines secular liberal and
Islamist groups that are really among
the new generation of lawyers academics
doctors civil rights activists and also
women activists as well on that leading
business disarm this challenge to in a
very courageous way one of the most
brutal regimes from the debtor face and
almost the shadow of God kind of
personality represented by
karakattakaran here I think what we see
now is this this uprising did not
happened because you know something have
you know stupid to speech here there I
think we should look at the simmering
sources of crisis simmering cause of
alienation blocking in the attempt to
reform or libyan were very generous and
when everything was was was shut in
their faces when the form was aborted
then people began to show in others
and other sources it's not just in Libya
in Tunisia people in Egypt the universe
i began to support and interact with the
score edition that challenging this very
very exhausted authoritarian new
tutorial state that running out of steam
and exhausted the generous time that
people give it over these years I should
maybe start because I could go on and on
forever I come from a long genealogy of
storytellers so forgive me for taking
long and I'd be glad to elaborate and
comment on other implications for the
future